it's so great to see you guys and happy
new year and i love to see the three of
you all of y'all back in the mix
together this season i saw the first
episode
oh it's gonna be good for sure um jenny
what is it like having your girl nicole
back in action
much needed much needed i always
pretended she was just sick and she
couldn't attend because none of us would
actually ever accept the fact that she
would never come back like we would
kidnap her at that point so i'm just
glad that she's like by my side every
time and i just don't have to text her
anymore she's actually there
oh
the besties are reunited like this is
great
i call you told me over wine that you
had to come back to the show because you
just had so much fomo so did you have
regrets after you left did you regret
coming back what gives why return after
you said i'm done i'm out of here got to
focus on the fans yeah i literally
needed a mental break i just feel like
mental health is huge for me and filming
a reality show
it definitely tests your psyche a little
bit and then i watch a season and
everyone's having fun and i'm like oh my
god i have so much fomo
and i was like i cannot
not go i didn't regret leaving because i
really needed it but i was like okay i
think it's time to come back because i
miss my roomies and definitely having
fomo and you know just watching them on
tv and i'm not with them it was just
like a horrible feeling i was like i
miss them so much so
it was time and the season was so much
fun i mean obviously there's drama here
and there there's a lot of things going
on but i think in general we all had the
best time
did you miss me i'm kind of freaking out
right now
is there a drama though with angelina
this season there's always drama with
angelina yeah we gotta work on our
relationship therapy is the key oh i
hope she and chris can work it out
because this is just it just doesn't
seem to be healthy you know it's a wait
and say yeah wait wait wait wait right
now
i don't know i always say mark my words
i feel like angelina and vinnie okay
sorry chris earmuffs i feel like they
they're gonna end up together in the end
wow
ah manifest it let's go yeah
what did your husband feel about you
rejoining the show nicole oh he was
totally cool he's like all right just
tell me when you're leaving i'll take
the kids yeah and you know it's totally
fine go have a great time but this time
i brought [ __ ] so i was really happy to
actually you know bring a child so i'm
not like homesick and you know i'm
actually content with going to sleep
hugging a baby so um [ __ ] and milani
had their best they were living their
best life drinking margaritas chilling
by the pool laying on the beach virgin
virgin well yes virgin of course
we gotta make sure we put that in
that one of y'all recently posted of the
two of them together because they
literally are like
y'alls minnie mae's and just to think
that they can have this amazing
friendship as well the personality is
the same too it's like that is a mini
jenny that is a mini nicole when i see
them together i've seen them playing on
the vacation like this is amazing i look
at them too look at them too it's really
dope and that's why i think that this
season is really special because
the amount that they get to share and
you get to see obviously you know
they're moms but you want to see what
that's like i love seeing them as moms
so you get the tv
when are you going to get in on this
when are you going to lock it down with
nikki or
whomever and you know
a married man be a father
for me i was happy to finally bring
somebody into this family so i'm still
i'm still adjusting to that so um they
get along very well which is really dope
and it's part of the vacation now so now
when we do this vacation she comes she
gets along with them which was important
to me and um i told her she didn't get
along with them she has to go she knows
that
it's important
how did nikki navigate life on the road
because you guys really had your
relationship in quarantine yeah so she's
handled it very well um she's very
organized person so and she doesn't like
making me late or anything like that
she'll she likes to sleep in but like if
she has to get up she'll get up she'll
wait to that last second but she'll get
up and then um she's like this is really
dope it's cool to have somebody to share
um like what i'm doing i love what i do
so and i have somebody to share with me
and have her on the road and she doesn't
come to every single gig but the gigs
that she comes to she gets to see her
her friends that are in that state and
that's what i do too when i go to la i'm
seeing my friends jersey seeing my
friends so she can do the same it's cool
that's a it's a great dynamic holly d's
growing up y'all i can't
stop it oh my gosh now can you guys
really party like you used to now that
your parents oh no
[Laughter]
oh you're gonna see it you're gonna
maybe you're gonna see one day this
season where we really like bring it
back and i feel like we did a great job
like we hanged
even though we were like hung over for
two days after but it was still
we still got it but ironically i feel
like i drank more now as a mom i just
pace myself and i left out by like 10 pm
you drink way more than you've ever had
before way more
oh my god i just can't party i can't
start at like 11 a.m as a mom i wait
till it hits five o'clock yeah yeah at
least
jenny i gotta say you and zach seem to
be navigating this life in this space
that you guys are in quite well i love
seeing him with the kids he'll take
grayson with him to the gym
um how much do you appreciate that about
him a ton a ton we are like truly a
family
he's truly a role model for the kids
he's super hands-on especially when it
comes to grayson
and his needs and he wants to be a part
of like every step of the children's way
so tomorrow actually we're going to be
um seeing him at the pnc center i
believe where he's wrestling and it's
going to be grayson and melanie's first
time seeing him like in front of a big
stadium and we're bringing nicole's
coming we're gonna bring like lorenzo
and [ __ ] and like really support him
and
you know it's gonna be a good day i'm so
excited
you need to be doing co-parenting with
roger quite well as well how do you do
that successfully yeah you just at the
end of the day you have to put the kids
first and he's very understanding with
like my schedule changing with filming
i'm not like a nine to five person so
you know he knows that i filmed jersey
shore and we're going to the keys and it
was great the production worked around
the kids vacation from school so he
knows that like they're just going down
there to have their best life live their
best life with their virgin margaritas
and pina coladas
in mind yeah
so um you know he's very understanding
with that and then i always make sure
that he gets them extra during the times
that i have them so like we just we
balance each other really well
you